I love this time of year because I love giving gifts,
but when I'm getting a present,
it's all about the thought that goes into it.
And that's why I'm so excited that we've teamed up with Etsy
to share how to make gift giving
a little more personal this year.
And joining me is their trend expert, Dayna Isom Johnson.
(audience claps)
Hi.
Hi Drew.
Hi Dayna, I'm so thrilled to be doing this with you.
I think we all need a little extra love this year.
So I think that's why it's really more important than ever
to find the most personalized,
the most unique and special gifts
for your family and friends.
And when you think about it, so many of us
will not be able to be in person to celebrate.
So that's what makes it even more important
to make sure that those loved ones
feel the love from your gift that they open,
even if you're celebrating from afar.
The holidays are all about the kids.
So why don't we start there.
How do we wow them?
We both know kids love to be creative, right?
They love to make things with their hands.
And the other thing they really like to do is to see items
with their name on it.
So you have there and I have something with me too.
They are custom personalized crayons,
and here's the bonus tip for this.
You are removing screen time.
You're really encouraging kids to be creative
and to spend time making things with their hands.
The other item that I liked, that's a bit of a throwback
are oversized, plushy, stuffed animals.
They're snugly, they're cuddly.
And again, we're removing some of that screen time, yes.
(giggles)
And like you said, it's really more about the experience
spending time together and being creative.
You look fabulous!
I love it, look at that octopus.
This is absolutely one of my favorite items.
I also think that not only is this an interactive toy,
but decoratively speaking,
this could make a corner of of a kid's room.
I am so obsessed with animals as are my kids.
So what is going on with Pat?
This is one of my favorite items I have to say.
So one thing that I really want people to think about
is our fur babies are members of our families,
and you have there with you, some personalized pet portraits
that I really love because it really is cementing
their place in the family tree.
And also the other thing that I'm really loving for pets
are personalized velvet collars.
So luxe and really perfect for our fur babies
when we go on those fancy walks together.
But again, you're pouring love into them
because they're members of our families.
This is so chic and so beautiful.
Okay, so apparently this is trending
in the men's department.
Yes, here's why, when you think about guys,
they never say to themselves, "Hey, know what I need,
I need a personalized portrait."
Or, "I need that great decor piece
to really set my living room off."
So this is our opportunity to set them up
for a stylish addition to their home,
because they're just never gonna think about that.
I'm a little surprised these were in the men's department.
I was like, men turned on by needle point.
I just did not see this happening.
That's actually me on the cover of InStyle
that I shot myself with my Detroit news t-shirt on
and I can't love this more.
Great, so then the other gift for guys
that I'm loving are cocktail dice
because we've spent so-
Yeah, this makes more sense.
(laughs)
Well, listen, look this is really great
because so many of us have thought to ourselves,
"Oh, you know, we've become amateur mixologists
with all our at-home happy hours."
So this is a great way to keep people creative and inspired.
What you got Drew?
What's your cocktail you're making?
Honey, kumquat, gin, ginger, rosemary,
creme de cassis, cherry bitters, and peach.
I want this immediately.
This sounds so good.
(laughs)
That sounds great.
And again, there's so many variations
that can come out of this.
So again, you're keeping the guys creative,
you're keeping them thinking
that they're the master mixologist for happy hour.
And then it's just really great.
Now what about the ladies?
So there's two main themes that I'm really loving
that can give some guidance for gifts.
The first is celestial, which I'm a huge fan of.
I love anything celestial themed.
You've got a really great constellation mug
that's personalized there with you.
I love it.
That's great.
It has our names in the handles.
Look, you can see Drew and Dayna, okay.
(water burbles)
(chuckles)
I love it.
It's so pretty.
And you can personalize it to any constellation you want.
Also, ice tie-dye.
Oh, Drew tie-dye has been such a major trend
throughout the entire year.
It's not slowing down at all yet.
It's easy and just fun and festive.
And I think what makes this really great for a gift
is that you can buy it as a DIY kit,
like the one you have there.
So it can really be given to any woman of any age
and they can personalize it based on their personal
style and taste.
This I'm for sure gonna get for my daughter,
all of who is a master tie-dyer.
But I love it.
And I'm so glad that the trend of 2020 really was tie-dye.
And these are just a few of the great gift examples
that we have on Etsy.
But we have millions of handcrafted, unique items
that are really perfect for any family member
on your gift list this year.
I don't know who I would be without Etsy.
I'm an Etsy girl, and I love these gifts.
Thanks, Dayna so much.
And make sure you check out etsy.com
to find the one of a kind gifts
that you can't find anywhere else.
(upbeat music)